es gibt viele faktoren die uns menschen
das überleben auf der erde langfristig
unmöglich machen könnten
der klimawandel und die kontinuierliche
erderwärmung beispielsweise kriege oder
aber eben auch asteroiden einschläge der
das leben auf der erde mit einem schlag
vernichten wie also können wir das
menschliche überleben sichern
eine antwort dazu kommt von einem
biotech startup aus den niederlanden und
klingt zunächst mehr als crazy eizellen
und samen sollen in einem ersten schritt
ins all transportiert werden und schon
2024 soll dann tatsächlich die erste
geburt im weltraum stattfinden
what the [ __ ] was genau steckt hinter
diesen plänen das erfahrt ihr jetzt bei
klick zum science fiction
hier geht es täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst er ganz herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
wir menschen auf allen möglichen
planeten überleben wollen müssen wir
zunächst wissen wie wir uns im all
reproduzieren so heißt es auf der
webseite von space laichen dem
niederländischen
biotechnologieunternehmen division schon
im jahr 2024 also in sechs jahren soll
die erste menschliche geburt im weltraum
stattfinden
nach angaben des unternehmens ist das
der entscheidende schritt damit wir
menschen demnächst auch auf anderen
planeten kolonien aufbauen können durch
den dreistufigen plan des
niederländischen start-ups bekämpfen wir
dann auch die möglichkeit die erde nach
einer katastrophe wieder zu bevölkern
konkret sollen in einem ersten schritt
männliche samen und weiblichen eizellen
ins weltall befördert werden und zwar
bereits ab dem jahr 2020
dies soll in einer art satelliten kugel
mit je 1.000 röhrchen passieren der
transport der samen und eizellen ins ei
könnte bis zu 125.000 us dollar kosten
also umgerechnet etwa 110000 euro
langfristig will das unternehmen so
einen vielfältigen gen pool aufbauen und
schon jetzt gibt es laut dem unternehmen
etwa 30 millionen menschen die an der
idee interessiert sind und ihre gene so
weiterleben lassen wollen die nächste
stufe mit dem namen missions lotus meint
dann die künstliche befruchtung als die
kosten hierbei könnten bis zu fünf
millionen dollar betragen also etwa 4,4
millionen euro
zudem wird für die künstliche
befruchtung mal auch noch einen space im
büro inkubator bemüht
ich den es noch zu konzipieren geht
zunächst sollen die schwangerschaft und
die geburt die auf die künstliche
befruchtung im all folgen auf der erde
geschehen erst im dritten schritt soll
dann die geburt des ersten babys im
weltraum stattfinden und zwar wie gesagt
schon im jahr 2024 die bezeichnung dafür
missions kreml
der plan des unternehmens sieht vor die
risiken so weit wie möglich zu senken
eben auf das niveau einer klinik geburt
zudem dürften nur mütter im all gebären
die bereits zwei kinder ohne
komplikationen auf der erde entbunden
haben doch ist das nicht völlig riskant
und unrealistisch eine schwangere frau
ins all fliegen zu lassen ein arzt würde
die hochschwangere bei dem etwa 35
stunden kurztrip in den weltraum
begleiten doch was soll dieser im fall
der fälle ausrichten hoffen lässt das
unternehmen auch welche rakete die
mutter für die geburt in den weltraum
transportieren soll und zudem auch in
welcher raumstation dies möglich sein
soll
und so sind fachleute nicht wirklich
optimistisch was diese pläne angeht dazu
die raumfahrt expertin claudia kessler
in einem interview mit der welt das
konzept ist im prinzip interessant und
natürlich diskutiert man unser
raumfahrern immer mal darüber wie das
weiterbestehen der menschheit im all
sicher gestellt werden könnte aber der
zeitplan den sich space live origin
davor stellt ist sicher sehr
unrealistisch und die umsetzung sowohl
technisch als auch ethisch sehr in frage
zu stellen das ganze projekt klingt also
sehr abenteuerlustig und erinnert ein
wenig an die aktion maßmann
hier wurden protagonisten und
protagonistinnen gesucht wie mit einem
one way ticket für mars fliegen wollen
um ihn dann zu besiedeln es hatten sich
auch tatsächlich viele freiwillige
gemeldet wir hatten hier bei pixum
science fiction ausführlich darüber
berichtet ursprünglich sollten die
ersten menschen schon 2022 auf dem mars
landen doch mittlerweile haben die
verantwortlichen das ganze um einige
jahre nach hinten geschoben zudem fehlt
auch immer noch eine stange geld um die
etwa sechs milliarden dollar teure
mission überhaupt durchzuziehen
wenn ihr garantiert kein video zu diesen
und vielen anderen themen bei pixum
verpassen wollt dann abonniert clixoom
auf englisch hier einfach draufklicken
denn da gibt es auch videopremieren wie
zum beispiel erst letzte woche das
interview mit harvard professor edward
zum thema ist humor eine alien
und da drunter geht's weiter mit school
of the future of artificial intelligence
replays tigers wir sehen uns auf dem
englischen kanal hoffentlich von pixum
stay tuned